hay temor que por la creciente inflación
y la volatilidad de los mercados la
economía estadounidense entre en
recesión estamos ya antes escenario o es
posible en tal caso en el corto plazo
bueno
la economía de Estados Unidos puede
entrar en recesión si no este año el año
que sigue se espera que en el segundo
trimestre del año de hecho el pri se
contraiga cerca del 1%, si bien
evidentemente este dos trimestres
consecutivos a la baja algunos dicen que
es una contracción una recesión técnica
Pues en este caso podría que
a lo mejor no ser así porque
independientemente de eso hay sectores
de la economía estadounidense sé que
continúan siendo sumamente fuertes entre
ellos pues el empleo no la tasa de
desempleo está en 3.6% más o menos pero
esto evidentemente no hay si hay unas
desaceleración en la economía
estadounidense lo que sí nos puede
llevar a una recesión te digo si no es
en este año sería durante el 2023 Y si
como bien dice llega a darse esta
recesión en Estados Unidos cuál sería su
impacto a nivel mundial y en particular
sobre la región latinoamericana
pues al final del día en Estados Unidos
es la principal Economía del mundo
latinoamérica en general y si vamos a
hablar específicamente por ejemplo de
México dependemos muchísimo de la
economía estadounidense por el lado de
las exportaciones Entonces esto
generaría evidentemente que haya una
desaceleración también en la región y
podría haber también una conversación en
los países de latinoamérica o los países
que dependan mucho de la economía
estadounidense Sí y hemos hablado de la
medida de la reserva Federal de subir un
0,75 las tasas de interés por la
inflación la medida podría ser
suficiente para dar un nuevo impulso a
la economía
pues de hecho los incrementos en la tasa
de interés de referencia este son otro
de los factores que podrían hacer que la
economía estadounidense caiga en una
recesión se espera y o es probable que
hagan otro incremento también de 75
puntos base y lo que genera la tasa de
interés de referencia a los incrementos
en la tasa de interés de referencia hace
que los créditos pues se reduzcan no
entonces el mercado inmobiliario podrías
pues este pues sufrir por las mayores
alzas en las tasas porque las personas
Pues evidentemente a lo mejor no
tendrían
podrían alcanzar algún tipo de crédito
no Entonces eso también podría acelerar
acelerar que haya una recesión económica